okay one of the last things from CPAC
that we're going to talk about and and
many so many of you emailed me about
this
is the Michael Knowles anti-transgender
moment now before I play this clip of
Michael Knowles and remember this is one
of the daily wire guys and I've been on
his program a couple of times and I
stopped doing it because I really got
nothing out of it and just you know his
audience doesn't like me and my audience
already knows me and there was just no
there was no benefit to going and
arguing with him about nonsense so
uh for a couple years now
the anti-trans and homophobic lines get
the best reactions at CPAC the CPAC
crowds have been increasingly dead
um other than when they do anti-trans or
homophobic stuff we saw it from Trump
last year we saw it from Ted Cruz at
some recent CPAC where he said my
pronouns are kiss my ass and you know
the anti-trans anti-home the anti-gay
stuff still does really well
and Matt Walsh who's another one of
these daily wire guys has really found a
lucrative niche in doing the anti-trans
stuff so clearly Michael Knowles is
trying to copy it he's saying hey whoa
the gravy train with the anti-tran stuff
is working really well for Matt Walsh
let me jump in on it so he's talked
about the need to eliminate
transgenderism so this is an example of
the anti-trans stuff from CPAC take a
look there can Vino Middle Way in
dealing with transgenderism it is all or
nothing if transgenderism is true if men
really can become women then it's true
for everybody of all ages if
transgenderism is false as it is if men
really can't become women as they cannot
then it's false for everybody too now I
want to let me address this for a moment
um they insist on this thing where they
want to know the truth about whether a
man can be a woman or whether a woman
can be a man and they want to argue
about it's all it's just truth and
biology Neil deGrasse Tyson in an
interview with Ben Shapiro a few weeks
ago made a really good point which is
listen
the TR if you want to talk about the
unassailable facts undeniable no one can
deny this the undeniable fact is that
people Express gender on a spectrum you
you can't deny that okay it is an
absolutely
incontrovertible truth that there is a
spectrum of gender expression for all
birth biological sex that exists people
Express gender on a spectrum you've got
more and less feminine men
and on and on so as Neil deGrasse Tyson
eloquently said there are aspects of
this which are questions for a biology
class there are aspects of this which
are questions for a Sociology class
there are aspects of this that are
questions for sports leagues to
determine rules no doubt and we've got
to figure out where that is but if you
want to talk about facts it is a fact
that people Express gender on a spectrum
and so when they talk about we just want
the truth can a man be a woman it's one
of the worst Faith but also ignorant
things you can say because all you need
to do is look at the world around you
and you know that it is true that gender
is expressed on a spectrum they they
want to make it a conversation about
something else let's listen to the last
few seconds and if it's false
[Applause]
especially since that Indulgence
requires taking away the rights and
customs of so many people if it is false
that's it for the good of society and
especially for the good of the poor
people who have fallen prey to this
confusion
transgenderism must be eradicated from
public life entirely now
numerous headlines after this speech
said oh he wants to get rid of
transgender people he just he wants to
get rid of him that's absolutely
horrible and Michael Knowles and other
people associated with him
have come to his defense with a line
like that's not true he didn't say do
anything to the people he said get rid
of the ism get eradicate transgenderism
not kill the trans people now I think we
need only one very simple hypothetical
to explore whether that is a good faith
defense of what Michael Knowles said
imagine imagine
that Michael Knowles or whoever had said
we need to eradicate Judaism
oh my God are you calling for for
genocide no no no no I didn't say
anything about eradicating Jews I meant
eradicate Judaism completely
do you think we would all accept that
and go oh okay
it's fine he's not saying anything about
Jews he's just saying eradicate Judaism
get rid of it completely oh yeah the
Anti-Defamation League would be fine
with that defense this is a pathetic
attempt to soften but also put others on
the defensive and some went for it there
are some news outlets that after Knowles
complained changed their headlines and
uh we all know what he's talking about
he is using he is saying out loud
in more explicit terms what a ton of
these right Wingers are thinking and
it's dangerous and it's disgusting and
it needs to be condemned and he can't be
allowed to walk it back by going no no I
didn't say anything about trans people I
met just get rid of the ism well what do
you what exactly do you mean by that
um this is what they are getting the
biggest reactions to we started seeing
it a year or two ago we've done
interviews about it the anti-lgbt and
now specifically focused on anti-trans
stuff it is back
they are going to ride it to a pot of
gold if they are allowed to Matt Walsh
already did Michael Knowles is trying
for it I would like to see some
Republicans if this is a great
opportunity for Mitt Romney this is a
great opportunity for whoever wants to
come forward and say that I have to
condemn let's see if any of them do